algunas victorias son estratégicamente
más importantes que otras y para el
ejército ucraniano recuperar el centro
logístico de Lima fue una victoria
significativa el presidente de Ucrania
dijo que vendrán más
sentirte a lo largo de esta semana se
han iniciado más banderas ucranianas y
se espera haya aún más en una semana
Rusia tomó el control del imán en mayo
lo que le dio a Moscú el control de un
cruce clave del río y una ruta de
suministro hacia el norte de la región
de donesk ahora expulsado en la ciudad
la victoria de Ucrania es para el jefe
de la otan una prueba de la capacidad de
kiev para desalojar las fuerzas rusas
hemos visto que han sido capaces de
tomar una nueva ciudad y que demuestran
que los ucranianos están progresando son
capaces de hacer retroceder a las
fuerzas rusas por su coraje por su
valentía por sus habilidades Pero por
supuesto también por las armas avanzadas
que están proporcionando los Estados
Unidos y otros aliados a pesar que el
Ministerio de defensa admitió que Estaba
sacando tropas del área de Lima por
temor a ser rodeados los soldados rusos
continúan tratando de evitar que los
ucranianos avancen hacia Severo niessky
en la sesión informativa del domingo el
ejército ruso no mencionó al imán pero
promocionó la destrucción de los
depósitos de misiles ucranianos
siete depósitos de armamento de
artillería y municiones fueron
destruidos también se destruyó un radar
de guía del sistema de misiles de
defensa aérea s-300 el tiempo también ha
sido crucial las tropas rusas fueron
expulsadas del imán justo después de que
Vladimir Putin declarara cuatro regiones
del este de Ucrania como territorio ruso
siendo una derrota punzante para Moscú